what do you think when a bully attacks a  kid is the kid justified in fighting  back self-defense yes 100 otherwise  you're also gonna get you're gonna get  bullied forever like i have friends and  they they go to a teacher or something  they do it that way and then you just  get picked on forever i got picked on a  few times and i switched into like if  you do that again i'll break your nose  because i know how to break noses it was  very dramatic but it was like okay and  that stops things right away but if it's  like oh no like don't do that or go talk  to an adult you're just gonna get  tortured throughout high school so yeah  self-defense for sure